Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday!
So several months ago, YouTube came to us to talk about a product they were working on
I should stop here and say that in general, I dislike change
Like I think YouTube reached its peak in July of 2007
when our channel looked like this and the site went down for maintenance almost every single Wednesday
I enjoy anachronisms like physical books, and I guess headphone jacks
So I was a little dubious but I'm genuinely excited about this change, which debuts today
But first let me back up and talk about a seemingly unrelated thing
For the last couple years I've wanted to make a YouTube show about health and fitness
called 100 Days
where two ordinary people spend a hundred days
eating well, exercising a lot
and doing everything that's been proven by randomized, controlled trials
to improve your health
We'd work with experts to learn why it's so hard to make
lasting changes in your life
and along the way we would measure our progress by testing stuff we want to be better at.
You know, like concentration tests, and push up contests, and hamstring flexibility, which at the moment for me, is just a little bit limited.
But there were two problems with this show.
First I didn't want to exercise and eat right for 100 days because sitting and pizza aren't just A way of life; they're MY way of life.
And second we wanted to make this show with lots of infographics and pictures and recipes and live shows so it would feel deeply connected.
But to do that would mean maintaining a billion new social media profiles.
A thought I just could not stomach.
This has been an ongoing problem because we've always had to built homes off YouTube for the non-video community stuff.
Like if you want to submit a photo or a painting to the art assignment, you have to do so via Tumblr or Twitter or Facebook.
we can't post worksheets or essays to accompany Crash Course videos
and to full engage with the project for awesome you have to follow us on social media
YouTube has always of itself as being about video, but for many of us its mostly been about community
I'd argue that the best YouTube channels aren't just shows you lean back and watch
They're communities you're part of and for a long time that was seen as YouTube's great weakness
Like in the early days YouTube actually released a product called "Lean Back"
that allowed you to watch videos without engaging with them because advertisers, espically back then
thought that engaged viewers were bad news like for one thing engaged viewers are less likely to watch ads
but also that the idea of mass media could be made
and shaped directly by the masses was kind of terrifying
but in spite of it all YouTube has continued to be a community platform
and today they have embraced that with the release of the community tab
this allows channels to post text, images, live videos and both jifs and gifs
these will show up in your mobile subscription feeds and on desktop here in the community section
you can also sign up to get new notifications for new posts in the community tab
with say a book review or a live show or results from the Nerdfighter census
its still in beta testing, there are lots of features to come but I am really excited about it because
one it means that Hank and I can finally make our the community hubs we always wanted them to be
two live shows are now easier and better, you can see this today when I do a live question Tuesday
and three in our beta testing the quality of discourse in comments in the community tab has been great
like upvotes actually work and also its much easier to moderate
I just realized I'm being paid to say these things, to be clear, I'm not
we have never and will never accept any kind of corporate sponsorship on Vlogbrothers
but we did work closely with YouTube on the development of the community tab and
I do think it's awesome which brings me back at last to 100 days
so starting January 1st you'll be able to watch my best friend Chris and me
try to have like the healthiest midlife crisis ever
the show will not just include videos but exercise routines, recipes, live shows and text posts
and it will all live right here on YouTube a community platform that also hosts videos
Chris incidentally is known to Nerdfighteria primarily for once appearing in a Vlogbrothers video
Wearing a speedo, but trust me you'll like him
So you can head over to YouTube.com/100days and subscribe now if you want to see me preform
like aerial acrobatics and hopefully, eventually, some day, touch if not my toes at least like my mid-shins
in a live show later today I'll be answering your questions about 100 days and
look forward to your ideas about how to make it awesome
Hank, I will see you on Friday, actually I will probably see you before then
thanks to the community tab